what's going on everybody welcome to the
23rd take interior tutorial video in
this video we're gonna be doing is we're
gonna add the next you know massive
chunk of code to our animation function
and this is going to basically allow us
to handle pretty much everything else
that we've thrown at her at our you know
program thus far so there's kind of two
ways for me to do this I can either do
it line by line or I could just you know
we could do it in like groups and show
the different stuff and I think what I'm
gonna do in this one chances are if
you've made it to this far in the
tutorial you're not needing instant
gratification by any means so I think
what the best way for me to do this you
know this next block of code is to
really just write it line by line we're
gonna have some functions again that
don't actually do anything yet and then
we'll kind of add the coverage for those
but it's gonna take a decent amount of
time to get through all of this so at
the end of this exception here this
exception is for take data right so if
data pay stick we try we try to do this
now that is really one to three paces
over so what we'll do is we come down
here way to the bottom and then we go
one two three and we have else so what
if the data is not tick data luckily we
can kind of handle this just based on
using the syntax ap or the sea of BTC
API or having and so that's what we're
gonna we're gonna do so else and then
we're gonna say if that counter is
greater than twelve so what are we doing
here the idea here is twelve is just a
magic number that I'm using
we're gonna probably change this down
the road we're just gonna throw in 12
for now that's just what's in the code
but if dedicate dat counter does not
equal is not greater than 12 then we
don't regenerate data so let me scroll
down to the very very bottom here okay
anyway so we won't actually refresh our
graph so to speak we're not gonna pull
data because the one of the larger sucks
of data and processing is redrawing the
graph as well as pulling new data so we
can make aunt the animation function we
can force the animation function to run
every second right we can do that but
the other but what we can do is we can
set that to run every second but we
simultaneously only in here whoops only
an animation function mm-hmm we can set
it down here with using our dat's
counter we can say well we only want it
to run every 12 times like every 12
seconds basically with 12 so that's kind
of how we're doing it what my idea is
down the road as we can allow the user
to say I want this to update every
minute or every 5 seconds or 1 second
and the reason that's going to matter is
using the the the C of B DC API so the
general data is not gonna really matter
but if you want to get like instant data
it's gonna cause quite the load to see
if B DC and you will have to pay for
that but for lightweight data or at
least this kind of data that's not
really lightweight data but for this
kind of data
well it'll be it'll still remain free
but anyway eventually we'll let the user
kind of decide how what kind of time
frames they want to use for now we're
just gonna say 12 so if that counter is
greater than 12 what do we want to do
well we want to try as always and then
we're gonna go ahead and just pre write
our accept so accept exception as e
print
string e and actually before stringy
let's go ahead and say failed in the non
tick animates okay now try what we're
gonna try is whoa by does very just
slightly between the other ones but it
won't be as big of a deal as it was with
tick data don't worry so we're gonna say
if exchange equals blow by or will be I
don't really know how you're supposed to
pronounce that then we're gonna say if
the top indicator equal or actually it's
not equal none
we're going to say am so itchy today a
equals p LT dot subplot to grid and then
again this is a six by six by four the
starting point here for this one is 1
and 0 and then rowspan is going to equal
5 and colspan will equal 4 and then
we'll just we'll take this copy paste a
to starting point 0 0
rowspan 1 and then also we're going to
share the axes here so share x equals a
and that's it for a oh and a 2 if else
right if top indicator does equal none
then we take this right here copy paste
and 0 0 and 6 4 so what are we doing
here in this code we're basically you
know setting up the subplots we're going
to be doing the exact same thing for all
the other exchanges it just so happens
with will be we don't have the same
we're not gonna have volume so so that's
why with will be it's it's very specific
so with with this
we're setting up basically the subplots
before we actually start throwing stuff
but you're gonna see with the other
exchanges we're gonna have many subplots
so let's go ahead and show that so that
was if exchange equals Wahby so only for
who we are we doing that otherwise we're
gonna have some checks quite like this
so we'll take this right here else and
then ash there's probably space there so
else if top indicator does not equal
none and bottom indicator does not equal
none what do we want to do here the main
graph is a right so a is gonna be PLT
that sub plot to grid the grid is as
usual it will be a six by four the
starting point this is a is the main
graph so the starting point will be one
down right because if there's a sub plot
above it it would start at zero zero so
the starting point here will be one zero
the row span here will be three and then
the call span here will be four next
we're gonna say because this is
basically if we're using both indicators
so this also leaves a row right below it
okay so um and actually two because we
have volume data and we have maybe an
indicator possibly so now we're gonna
say a two and this will be our volume
equals this and let's go ahead so we
don't you know retype a ton equals this
exact same data the start point for
volume is actually four zero
rowspan is gonna be one colspan stays
the same so that's volume now let's copy
this paste it and in fact let's go ahead
I commented this in my in my main code
and I'd like to go ahead and do it again
just so people don't get confused by the
code so that's main graph that was vault
that's volume now a three
a three is well a three will actually be
the bottom indicator so a 3 equals PLT
subplot to grid 6 4 and the starting
point for a 3 is 5 0
rowspan is indeed one call span 4 and
then we're actually we're gonna let's
just copy all this paste and now this
right here is your top indicator and
we're gonna call it a 0 we have to kind
of we have to put it below because all
of these are sharing the axes of a which
we have not added but we will I guess um
so the starting point here will be a 0 0
and the rest stays the same and now
let's go ahead and throw in our share x
equals a comma so let's go ahead and
copy that paste paste and that's all at
this thing we have to do so that's
setting up the basically all of the
indicators and the subplots if we have a
top indicator and a bottom indicator now
the next question would be obviously if
that would be the most indicators L if a
top indicator is not equal to none then
what and the reason how come we can get
away with this so we're only what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say because we
don't have to say L if top indicator
equals none yet bottom indicator or top
indicator doesn't equal want none but
bottom indicator does and then flip flop
and have a bunch of questions because
that is already covered by we ask this
if statement first for a very good
reason so if this statement isn't true
but this statement is true de facto it
means we have no bottom indicator so we
don't have to worry about that so the
order does matter it
if when it comes to your logic so just
kind of keep that in mind and that's
also why we throw an L if statement in
there anyways so L if top indicator does
not equal none what do we want well we
want fairly similar graphs so let's go
ahead and just kind of let's just copy
and paste and we know we don't have a
bottom indicator anymore so I'll just
delete that and then now you've got your
main main graph it will basically start
in the same position as it always had
the only difference is it's now gonna
span four rows but it will still span
obviously four columns then we've got
volume data volume is gonna start
basically one down so five zero and it's
information otherwise stays I you know
exactly the same okay so that it would
be when the top indicator is none now
we're gonna set up l if bottom
indicators not equal none
whoops none and now we basically do the
exact same thing only instead of top we
have a bottom so it's copy-paste change
this two will go ahead and change that -
actually yeah - and then we're called
this one now I'm just totally lost that
was top indicator so this would be three
okay so this is when there is no top
indicator there is instead only a bottom
indicator so this our start point would
be zero zero okay everything shifts up
basically so zero zero for the main
graph four zero for this graph and then
this bottom indicator five zero okay so
that's it for bottom indicator and then
of course we could find ourselves that
we only have price and volume data so
else we basically have the this right
here copy-paste now this gets to span
five rows and this
but they'll start it at five it shifts
down okay so that's the setting up of
our subplots and the gridding of our
subplots to handle price volume whether
or not we have just a top indicator we
have both top indicator and bottom
indicator or whether we just have a
bottom indicator okay so now that logic
covers all of that and now we're ready
to actually begin pulling the data and I
think what I'll do is all have us
pulling that in the next video so if you
have any questions or comments on this
video please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and donations until next
time